so this is pretty funny actually because
uh the majority of the exercises I have
prepared today are actually taken from
the exact same game so that's pretty
interesting but it's a very interesting
game so we're going to be looking here
um
all right so right I'm minimized again
um okay so in this position we're gonna
be looking at a game where
I was playing Black against the uh I am
Bryce tiglon
um it was from Washington which is where
the game was played and I believe the
right at the end of 2019 so just a
couple of months before covid so uh it's
black to play here and so we can
immediately notice that the King on H3
is under uh extreme pressure at the same
time it's not so easy to proceed as
black as well so how can we continue
here
um
uh yes you there
um yeah so Soroka fate is a
Pretty Natural move to bring in The Rook
into the game
um so after work I think what do you
believe that white is going to play
yeah yeah very good so far
yeah so uh you and uh
so DaVinci in the audience and sdsvr are
correct so far that after book f8 White
would probably play Rook 8 F1 so after
Rook 8 F1 when you think about Black's
position are we doing well or what's
going on
yes that is correct
so you have to be pretty careful
otherwise you're just going to lose
because we're down two pieces
Queen E5 looks stronger I need to lift
my Rook through
F6 to H6 so yeah the problem is that uh
if you play a move like Queen E5 White's
still going to play Rook F1 and you're
just not going to be able to uh hold on
to your attacking position for that much
longer
um
yeah so Rook F1 and a pair of Rooks
would come off and from there the attack
is going to be relatively weak
sadly
for the record I did not make the right
choice in this game
then H5 a more direct approach yes H5 is
very direct H5 is actually what I played
in the game so the good news is that
you're thinking like me who wasn't I am
at this point
um
unfortunately the bad news for you
Pastor is that thinking like me in this
case was the wrong case because H5 is
actually losing straight away which
actually leads us right into our next
example but before that let's go on to
sdsvr's suggestion here we're after Rook
of Fate Rook F1 you mentions a check on
H6 which is difficult to calculate all
right so uh so after Rook f8 Rook F1
Queen H6 what do you see there SDS VR
oh
pastor says that it's a perpetual and uh
and he is correct although perhaps the
details of it are a little fuzzier than
would be expected but after Rook f8 so
in this position white is more or less
forced to play Rook F1
um it's like for example if white just
makes some nothing move like Bishop C6
um black is already able to play Rook F2
and on some queen move there is Queen H6
with Rook F4 Checkmate coming up
so uh so yeah white is forced to play
Rook F1 in order to prevent Rook F2 from
happening but in this case black is able
to make a Perpetual here with Queen G5
King H2 between H4 qg2 green G4
so uh
erikido is correct so far
um
or uh okay not exactly so the problem
with with your line there uh urikido so
Rito suggested Queen H5 and then Queen
G4
um but the problems after Rook takes F3
Rook takes F3
um I believe in this position white is
able to play uh
King H1 and since the White Queen swings
over to H2 you're gonna have to take the
Knight but this position is losing given
that we are down a piece here
um
so yeah the correct line is still the
one that was mentioned uh by sdsvr and
judged by Pastor but uh in this position
uh White is able to swing the queen to
H2 however after Queen takes E4 uh
definitely a very peculiar Perpetual
check but it does indeed still happen if
white wishes to play Rook F3 first
then
um I believe White's actually in serious
danger of losing after Rook takes F3
since Rook H3 will probably pick up a
queen here
yeah yeah so so the key reason or sorry
okay perhaps Queen tags F3 is actually
better
um since we still seem to have the same
sort of Perpetual anyway what was I
saying so the key to this position is
realizing that as black uh the objective
is actually to draw since the key is
that you have to understand back into
losing in other cases so that is why
this position is difficult to do
um
since yeah if black does not go for this
pressure we'll check is in fact a losing
as we are about to see uh in the case of
what happens after H5 since it is now
white to move and so how should white uh
address this situation
okay
we're playing rookie F1 right away
so DaVinci what do you think that uh
what is it that you think that uh that
black wants to play on the next move
oh your audience sound quite young are
they able to solve these puzzles well
the audience is quite young but that
does not mean that they are necessarily
weak
um yeah H5 creates a much more serious
threat so in this position black is
threatening to win right away by playing
Queen G4 like for example it'd be like
Rook F1 where do I have Queen G4 and uh
the Knight on G3 is going to be hanging
after a while and Rook takes G3 will win
the game so it's very important for
white to make a move that somehow
protects this Knight or otherwise
against the threat of Queen G40 H4
oh yes yes of course uh us Masters are
among the youngest behind countries like
India yeah something like that
sdsvr it's just Queen H2 yeah so the the
most uh the the most pertinent candidate
moves that are available to White are
going to be Queen G2 and queen H2 since
those are pretty much the only moves why
can you play to avoid this queen G4
Queen H4 threat as they allow white to
protect Moto G3 so the key is to make
the choice between these two moves
I think Queen G2 is better okay Queen G2
was white was what white chosen the game
um
let's see if we can get a couple of more
answers here from the people in twitch
chat before going through some blinds
um
all right so it looks like we have a
pretty even split here with Pastor
favoring Queen H2 and SDS for her
favorite sorry uh favoring an SDS you
are a favor and queen G2 so yeah as
expected it's a fairly tough position to
understand
so Queen G2 as was chosen by my
International Master opponent is
actually the wrong move so point so
Queen H2 is superior because of some
very powerful counter play along the H
file so uh for example
um in the case of the move H4
after white can simply play Rook af1 so
after H takes G3 so in this position
it's actually quite possible for black
to win The Exchange on F1 but after
Bishop takes C6 and E takes D5 white
black is not going to be able to stop
these three connected pawns and leaving
white with a winning position so
um so after Queen H2 black is pretty
much forced to play the move rook af8 in
order to avoid this line then and then
after Rook F1 so of course black does
not want to be exchanging uh pieces so
uh
yeah the a big problem for black is that
if you take an F1 white is not going to
have taken out form with a rook which
would potentially allow a Checkmate on
G4 white would take with the Knight on
F1 and every all the key squares appear
to be protected so uh White would be
left with a winning position here so
then the key is what happens on the Move
Rook 8 to F4 with the threat of Rook H4
coming up and if white takes an F3 then
there's Queen G4 with Queen takes F3 and
in fact white would lose here again so
this is the subject of our next exercise
or perhaps it's not actually what is
wrong with me uh okay I think I
originally intended it to be that way
but after Rook 8 to F4
um
yeah because the queen is present on H2
there's a possibility for white to
retreat to G2 straight away with King G2
and yeah white should end up with a
winning position here so
um yeah anyway so this did not happen in
the game as Queen G2 was chosen so a few
moves down the line we reached this
position
um where in uh I had succeeded in
trading one of my Rooks for the White
Queen after some time of pretty much
normal moods
so in this position it is black to move
and find the best way to proceed
yeah a lot of subs today pretty good
yes I should flip the board
personally I never really cared too much
about people flipping the board or not
but a lot of students and such tell me
it matters
followers ain't no subs
indeed that is correct
um yeah H4 is definitely possible
um
H4 is believed or not what I played in
the game and happens to be really bad
it's very tempting though so I
understand why you would say it since a
lot of White's normal moves map position
are losing which we'll go into a little
bit more detail in shortly
um
yeah so so I guess we can just do that
right now so after H4
um so white can move the Knight to
several different places but the most
desirable ones like 94 would allow
rotates F3 and picking up the Rook on G1
to achieve ab2 advantage
so why does force to play 92 and at
first it looks like white is facing a
serious problem after Queen F5
um
but this is in fact the subject of the
next exercise so we'll be getting there
momentarily for the meantime uh yeah in
the meantime we're gonna be looking at
this position right here so a couple of
suggestions here so Pastor suggests Rook
takes F3 but after Rook takes F3 so it
would be possible to play Queen G4 and
perhaps try picking up the Knight on G3
through playing H4 but this is not uh
really sufficient for black
um
if anything for white is already
possible play rookie one and simply
Advance the E Pawn with a most likely
winning position for white
so yeah again that is not uh quite there
but
um
yeah fairly close
Rook H4 and queen D2 suggested by Dr
drink and drive good to see you again
um yeah I've been in this position white
has several defenses simply 92 already
appears to be uh good enough or even
Bishop E2 also I don't see anything
uh is there anything particularly wrong
with Rick F2 perhaps not but I'm sure
the white should just favor 92 which
just looks a little bit uh safer
um
yeah so this is a really weird position
so the key to understanding this
position is pretty much just knowing
that uh if black is able to capture the
E5 Pawn then the exposed King for white
should lead to very good counter play
but the problem is if you take an E5
right away then you're very liable to
drop the H Pawn which would not be ideal
for black since white is of material
here with a rook and two pieces versus a
queen and a pawn potentially there can
be two pawns but yeah it's not optimal
here and yeah Dr drink can drive has the
correct idea you best knew in this
position for black is G6 so after G6 it
turns out that pretty much no matter
what white plays there is no reasonable
way to protect the E5 pawn and indeed
after E6 something like Queen E7 is
perfectly fine and this position black
has quite a serious Advantage as the
White Queen side pawns are very weak and
the white king is unlikely to find any
form of safety in the near future so
yeah very difficult position to
understand stand but yeah G6 is the best
move here and it turns out that just by
playing solidly Black is able to pick up
that E Pawn and achieve a great
advantage
so uh the next exercise we're gonna be
looking at begins in this position after
uh Queen F5 check so in this case it is
white to move again and how should White
address the problems in this position
the exception of the rule of Queen's
superiority case over three pieces yes
absolutely yeah the problem there for
white is that the king is really bad and
the queen side pawns are unlikely to
survive for too long so that's why it
ends up being good for black
right so Bishop G4 is definitely a
strong move to consider of course then
it's also important to consider what
white is going to play against that so
yeah please
yes what black is going to play against
that so yeah please take a second to do
so
foreign
nice
yeah very nicely done from Doctor drink
and drive so if white wishes to try to
retreat the cane protect the bishop then
after Rook C4 again there's a problem
for for white and which black is going
to pick up the E5 Pawn likely the C5
pawn and possibly the B2 Pawn so uh in
this position black should have some
small advantage in any case the position
is very practically difficult to play
for white since the king remains like
very exposed
so after Bishop G4 Queen D3 at first it
looks like this is going to be pretty
good for black since the case of King
takes H4 black is able to abuse the pin
on the fourth Rank and meet Rook takes
the four with Queen H2 picking up one of
the Rooks with a massive Fork here this
actually would happen in the game as it
turns out that even though the Rook on
G1 is going to fall uh the black king is
very weak and the E Pawn is very strong
which should allow white to make a draw
somehow but darker drink and drive
points out the best move here Rook G3
so after Rook G3 the threat to the queen
mix is that black does not have time to
capture an F1 and after H takes G3 Rook
takes out four white just has a huge
material advantage here and combined
with that super powerful E6 pawn and the
now safe white king as their normal
pieces to combine with the Queen White
would be left with a seriously winning
Advantage here so very nicely done
um yeah so that is the correct way for
white to play in this position
and instead we're going to be rerouted
to this position which occurred uh much
later on in the game
um
so yeah but as you can see this this
pretty clearly came from the position
after King G5 and queen 6g1 and then in
fact King G6 was played and I played a
queen B1 check so after King G6 Queen B1
check we're going to be looking at what
should white play here
foreign
Bishop F5 is very natural and indeed
happened in the game but
not a terribly good move unfortunately
mostly because uh White just has white
has a really powerful idea here which is
very easy to underestimate that is
indeed what happened in the game
well you only have a couple of legal
moves so at this point it seems like a
process of elimination but yes King F7
is the best move
um since after King F7 it turns out that
if black wishes to play normally with a
move like Queen takes B2 is actually a
very serious danger of being checkmated
straight away on the H file which is
very difficult for black to uh to
actually address
so every km7 black should be forced to
play Queen H7 but now the white king is
able to run to the queen side and leave
white with some Advantage after
capturing the C6 pawn and advancing the
e-pawn yes
the A2 public truck
um so you take the A2 pound check that's
a great question but again white simply
needs to move the bishop away so that
now the queen is under attack and Rook
H4 mate remains a possibility
um so in the game Bishop F5 happened and
uh I still severely underestimated this
idea of King F7 so I actually took on B2
and uh what should have happened in the
game was King F7 and uh pretty sure I
have to resign pretty soon
uh yeah I'm not able to cover H3
excuse me
well isn't white threatening track made
in one
yeah
yeah so I actually took on B2 but it
turns out that this move is not that
great because black is able to bring the
queen to H1 and create a defense on the
H file by playing G5 and uh yeah black
is going to bring the queen back to H6
and G7 and a draw should be possible
here so that is why King F7 first is a
better implementation of the idea
believe it or not I actually did end up
winning this game even though this
happened in the game my opponent did not
find King F7 and somehow I managed to
win despite my best efforts so
yeah I mean it really feels like I tried
as hard as possible to lose this game
but somehow I managed to win in the end
so just another example of how chaotic
chess can be
okay so yeah just as a bit of a reprieve
from that exercise let's do a an easier
one for now on this game was played in
the 2019 World open so I was playing
Black against a player who
a player from Canada around 2200 22.50
feet a something like this so yeah
simply we have black to move in this
position
um
obviously there's a protected pass Pawn
in B2 which is very strong but at the
same time white does have a pretty
annoying skewer that is ready for black
in this position so how should we
continue as black to get out of this
problem
so chess lovers suggests Bishop D6 which
is definitely a possibility Bishop D6 is
very tempting because if white takes on
D6 you're able to eliminate the rook and
play an in-between move a B1 Queen
uh sadly uh why you can white can use
their own in-between move to capture the
rook and take a D6 which should leave
white with a pretty good position there
but yeah pretty good idea but there is
something a lot more powerful for black
available in this position
yeah drink and drive gets it again so uh
the funny thing here is that the white
Rook on D1 is actually temporarily
overloaded as it is forced to protect B1
and the White Queen
so you could think of it by thinking
about it like how uh pretty much you
could consider the White Queen to be uh
hanging at the moment so by playing
Queen B7 so first of all on Queen takes
B7 Rook takes B7 black has escaped the
uh
black has escaped the loss of material
and so
yeah black is up with this really
powerful Pawn on B2 and should win the
game fairly smoothly and after Bishop
takes B8 again because this Rook is
overloaded is not capable of covering
both of these squares so a simple
promotion is possible
and Rook takes behind Queen takes D5 so
of course not an option for black and
the Queens happen to protect each other
unfortunately uh I do not get to keep
the pair of queens for very long since
after Rook takes E7
um I I run into a sort of back rank
problem uh Queen E7 Rook B1 is obviously
not a possibility and rookie seven on
that was Queen d8
yeah very good that's exactly what
happened after Queen takes D1 Queen
takes D1 and queen takes E7 black has
the extra x black has an extra exchange
here and uh perhaps even more
importantly uh White has is faced with a
situation where because the B8 Bishop is
hanging white is not able to prevent the
exchange of Queens on E1 and therefore
leaving black with a completely winning
end game since just for a good measure
even the Z2 Pawn is not salvageable and
white ended up resigning here
all right so let's uh uh all right so
let's move on to the next example great
job to everyone welcome to ended up
finding that so in this case we have a
black to move
black indeed did just capture a rook on
D1
uh oh wait it appears that someone has a
question about the previous example
Queen B3 uh where would Queen B3 have
been possible
uh
where would that have been possible as
dsvr
I mean it's obviously possible but I
mean again you would just simply take
the queen and move away with a uh and
yeah again black has uh the protect past
Pawn on B2 and uh should be pretty much
uh should be pretty much uh winning for
black here since that pawn on B2 is not
going to be stoppable at the end of the
day
um but yeah you're right it would be a
better try for for white than what
happened in the game which is which is
pretty immediately losing but at the end
of the day everything should be losing
for white anyway so yeah in this example
um my friend I am Craig hilbius playing
white and Grand Master Brandon Jacobson
is playing Black so uh in the game black
uh somehow played like Knight F2 and
took on D1
um and white has decided to meet this
with Knight D5 creating a sort of uh in
between move also forking the queen and
Rook
so the task here is to find what black
should do about this
Rook C3
um
so Rook C3 is a very interesting
possibility
um
so in Rook C3 I believe White
takes the queen on B6
and so if you take the queen on B3 white
simply recaptures and this is possible
but
at the end of the day Black's Advantage
here if it exists at all is very small
the Knight is going to migrate over to
C4 and it's doubtful that you have a
great Advantage here but definitely
possible I mean a simple move like Queen
A5 or something after takes E7 you would
probably take on C7 and um
and yeah most likely you'd have a pretty
similar Pawn structure to that
so yeah not a bad move but there is
slightly better here
indeed it is black to move chest lover
yeah no worries
uh White wasn't I am in this game
um
looking at Queen just lover says looking
at Queen A5
um yeah it definitely is important to
consider that's for sure
well Pastor suggests to move Bishop A4
but
I think black is able to
I think White's able to take the bishop
on A4 there
yeah it doesn't seem to work out too
well for black there but clever idea so
yeah it looks like
yeah Julian's right there uh so after
Knight C3 the key is that and this
position after Pawn takes C3 Rook takes
C3 you will end up in a very similar
situation to the initial move Rook C3
but indeed uh the white B Pawn is
missing from B2 so of course it's just a
version with an extra Pawn if white
wishes to take on B6 you would just
simply capture the queen and take on B6
and black has an extra Pawn here and
should be a decent bit better in this
end game
and assume applies from Knight takes C3
Pawn takes C3 White's not able to
recapture any of these pawns and
encounter that pinned Queen
um yeah pass uh so SDS VR there has a
bishop A4 but yeah unfortunately uh this
position white can simply return the
queen to B3
oh you're right actually the queen on B6
is hanging yeah very good
yeah so that actually uh so that's
actually really bad uh Bishop A4
unfortunately so so yeah definitely not
uh an optimal situation there
um
yeah so in the game black I actually
played Queen A5 and if I'm not mistaken
yeah white play Knight takes C7 and
white actually had some Advantage here
but uh later in the game white ended up
messing up and they ended up uh black
actually ended up winning the game you
know pretty interesting end game uh I
recommend investigating the game to
anyone who wishes to play this Pawn
structure since black uh handled the
deep end game extremely well
okay so the last set of examples uh just
like the first set of examples are all
taken from the same game
so in this game I was playing Black
against a roughly 2200 ish feed a player
um and so basically what happened was
that I had played some preparation
against the F3 Nims of Indian evolving a
quick D5 and meeting A3 with Bishop D6
which I was introduced to by someone in
this room
um and so so yeah so basically uh I I
developed an initiative very early and
we culminated in this position when
white was finally afforded the
opportunity to Castle short so here we
have black to move and how to increase
the pressure
oh yes that would be that would be a
good idea
the queen has to defend D2 uh drink and
drive is absolutely correct about that
the White Queen is forced to hold the uh
D2 Rook
yeah
I mean that wouldn't be very impactful
why you would play Queen takes D2 follow
up with Knight C3 and perhaps black is a
little bit better since black does have
control of the open files and the
superior minor piece but nothing too
serious there
so B6 is definitely a strong
consideration here
um
does the Queen have to stay in the
diagonal
because it has to protect your workout
yeah but you also have to look over at
least
yeah Julian is is right about that uh so
the immediate B6 which would be a very
nice move to play
um so uh Queen B4 would lose to a pretty
funny sequence uh assuming nothing is
possible since the queen eventually has
to go to D2 square but white can simply
capture on d8 and if you take the queen
Rook takes E8 should actually leave
white with a better position now with
the two books against the queen so you
would most likely be forced to uh take
on a date with your rook and now white
can do uh virtually anything perhaps
Queen B4 is is fine
um and uh again black is probably better
here with the more active pieces and the
bishop against the Knight but nothing
too serious
there's something a lot more devastating
that black has available here
uh pastor says I think I'm penetrating
the second rank after Queen V6 and then
corrects himself and indeed Pastor is
correct the second time around
chess Super Bowl Edition yes
um
yeah I was actually asking earlier if
anyone was watching this stream in the
Super Bowl concurrently but I don't
think anyone is doing that
oh wow okay so we do have someone who's
doing that in chat uh yes sorry to
interrupt you
all right now
uh rookie to should be good enough
okay
[Music]
um
yeah so there's a lot to unpack there
but yeah Rook D3 is a very interesting
idea so uh Rook D3 uh is is nice because
um in the case of um
Rook takes G3 Bishop takes D3 the pin on
the Knight makes it so that white is
going to be the losing material here and
uh The Rook has been removed from the
sensitive d8 square and therefore both
B6 and Rook E5 would be acceptable ways
of removing the queen from The Rook so
black does create a threat by playing
Rook D3
and so there are a couple of moves that
black that white can play here
um
if white uh so wishes to
avoid uh if white so wishes then white
can try to remove the knight from E2 but
this of course allows black to execute
the threat with Rook E5
A5 and then G5 forcing the queen to let
go of The Rook on D2 and uh
unfortunately for white there are too
many hanging pieces here in Queen E3
makes it so that white cannot address
all of them at the same time
so Knight C1 which is very tempting is
not sufficient for a white to survive
and um
a queen A4 is another interesting try
because a white is able to release the
queen from this B6 threat as well as
create some pressure on E8
does Julian have or anybody else have a
better suggestion uh have a continuation
here available
attention which was to take D2 and claim
that E2 and B2 are hanging
and I was happy to just went up on
it yeah I mean that's that's pretty
valid I mean to be honest that's that
that's already pretty good
um do to be honest
um
but yeah it is stronger there is some
slightly stronger uh continuation here
it looks very odd but by starting with
Queen B6 you're forcing the king to for
make its own back rank issue and now
after Queen d8 Rook takes D3 Bishop
takes D3 the pin remains as strong as
ever
um and Rook fd1 Rook takes E2 is pretty
sad for white on account of all these
pins
so after Rook D3 which turns out to be
the correct move white in the game
played rook fd1 and that leads us to our
next exercise believe it or not
okay so in this position
um
so now we have this position with black
to move
um
so
so I should start off by mentioning
that uh
Rook takes E2 here as suggested by
Julian earlier is definitely a strong
move candidate
um but it's important to think about how
white can possibly defend after that
and if there may be something better in
the starting position
uh drinking Drive suggests Queen G5 but
I think the pin along the fifth rank is
very annoying and indeed after
Rook takes D3
um yeah this doesn't seem to work out
since on Rook takes E2 which I assume
was probably the idea why couldn't force
a queen trade with Queen DH remember the
King on G8 is very vulnerable and in
fact black would actually probably lose
the game here
and of course Bishop takes D3 Queen
takes G5 is nothing particularly special
for black so yeah unfortunate yeah Queen
d8 is the key idea there for white
wait oh sorry what'd you say like I
don't see any defense for white after
rookie two like okay I mean okay so so
this is not a great puzzle in the sense
that like uh like after rookie two black
is also winning but it's not like
immediate
um if that makes any sense like like you
can reach a line where you like up a
pawn with a great position but there's
no like immediate win in that position
um whereas uh there is a move here that
like ends the game
immediately but it's it's really
difficult honestly I'm not uh expecting
Too Much from the audience or the chat
here not because you guys are bad but
just because it's really hard I mean
when I was uh When I Was preparing this
this exercise uh just this afternoon
um it's just something that I also
didn't understand for a little while so
yeah
so drink and drive suggests Rook E5 so
after rookie five
um let's say perhaps uh so here there's
actually a lot of different moves to
consider which is
a little bit bizarre
um but probably the most uh pertinent of
them is simply uh
Queen C7 after which it's not so obvious
how this is uh different from the game
situation
um
so
here yeah
uh do you think that it works
so what happens if white takes her Queen
wait hold on hold on so so you want to
play Queen takes B2 and then Rook takes
D1 yeah
so white has like one oh white is two
legal moves but one potential move king
of two
I think we're probably down to Queen
right
yeah it doesn't look too hot
oh thank you so much for the raid Akash
is Rook takes F3 just absolute Insanity
um
well it depends on how you define
insanity but for me uh taking a winning
position and dropping a whole Rook is
pretty is pretty rough
um
yeah it doesn't seem to uh it doesn't
seem to work out too well yeah Pastor
gave the sample a line of Queen G5 and
then Queen E3 but white is a bunch of
ways to defend I think Rook F2 is
probably just the simplest with an extra
look for white
um
okay so yeah the problem for black here
is that the move Rook takes E2 is very
tempting since white is not able to take
on E2
um
on account of the the fact that the D1
Rook would be hanging in that case and
indeed this is what I played in the game
because I didn't understand the solution
but after Rook takes D3 Bishop takes D3
Rook takes D3
Queen G6 looks like it's winning as we
are creating a double attack on the rook
and queen takes GT Checkmate but after
queen d8 king H7 uh White is able to
prevent the entry of the black queen
with the move G4 and obviously this is
not good for for white after after Rook
takes B2
um I mean the lack of the pawn white
king is exposed positions probably
around -3 or so but at the same time uh
you know like there there's there's a
little bit of Chess left to be played
and there is no immediate win here in
the game white completely lost his
marbles and played G3 here which allows
Queen H5 and uh the queen simply
infiltrates to C2 and I delivered a
Checkmate very shortly
um
so uh yeah so the key here is in fact
the move rookie five so after Rook E5
white has a couple of options but almost
all of them are almost impossible to
refute in advance in a real game as so
in the case of the move Queen A4 which
looks very natural since the queen is no
longer needed to protect D2 and can
instead Shore up D1 preventing Rook
takes E2 black simply plays Rook takes
E2 anyway and meets Rook takes E2 with
this gorgeous in between move Queen C6
um so the queen is not able to escape
this attack as The Rook on D1 is needed
to be covered and of course the Rook
goes with check meaning that black is
going to be out with left with an extra
Bishop here
and on a move like Queen takes A7 white
has moved the Queen off of the fifth
rank so uh the insertion of Rook E5
means that uh Queen G5 here is going to
uh be winning since G4 uh now allows
simply Queen H4 and the queen should be
able to enter into E1
perhaps other moves are fine as well
perhaps Queen C1 is a little bit easier
yeah but the queen G5 has a double
attack on G2 and C1 so yeah
um
yeah my bad uh po crew yeah the uh my
notes I just have Queen G5 are the
winning symbol so yeah
um and no I did not find this in game in
the game I played Rook takes E2
um but anyway so yeah the key here lies
after Queen C7 and after Rook takes E2
so it appears that not much has changed
since on Queen G6 we have the same case
with queen d8 and uh with queen d8 and
then G4 so this is exactly the same
position so it looks like not too much
has changed
um
and in the case of Queen G5 white has
the move Queen d8 so
and at first it looks like any other
attacking move like Queen H4 or queen V2
still seems to allow some sort of Queen
C8 Queen F5 check in fact I believe this
would actually be losing for for black
after Queen F5 which is kind of funny
but so this position uh is the subject
of the next exercise which is the last
one and so we'll be doing this one here
uh where did you learn to play like this
is their insane type no I did not see
rookie five in the game uh unfortunately
um
yeah I did not find rookie five in the
game I played Rook takes E2 as I pointed
out before and um yeah and I was I was
pretty prepared to just try to just
slowly win the position after G4 Rook
takes B2 but white played G3 and allowed
the infiltration of the black queen into
the second rank with a quick win
um anyway so yes we are here and this is
our final exercise for today and
probably the stupidest of all of them so
yeah it is now uh black to move and find
the best way to immediately win the game
well as we mentioned before Queen G6 uh
it's the same position as before after
Queen d8 and then G4 where again we can
take in V2 but uh game is not
immediately over the problem is that the
queen on d8 controls all these important
squares here
um so Queen G5 and such is not possible
but there is something a little bit or I
shouldn't say a little bit but there is
something much stronger that is
available in this position
so sdsvr suggests Rook takes G2 which is
uh also possible and definitely
something I considered in the game or
with the analogous position with the
queen A5 so you would be able to pick up
the Rook on D3 but uh you're definitely
or I should say you're pretty much
definitely not going to win the game uh
you can of course give Perpetual a check
whenever you want but white is not even
down material here so it's very doubtful
we can do a whole lot here
and Pastor has succeeded again in
refuting his own suggestion with Queen
G5 Queen d8 check forcing a trade of
Queens there
I'm tired yeah I get it it's been a
while
yeah Gypsy 999 also has encountered the
same problem with Queen H4 Queen d8
check
yeah at the end of the day why is
waiting after most of the sorry black is
winning after a lot of the normal moves
um
but the problem is that again white
always gets counter player some sort of
Queen dude or queen C8
uh well I mean you can but the problem
is your Rook is hanging so after G3 you
okay well I guess you actually don't
lose because you can play Queen E7 but
you're very close to to losing
and uh
yeah
all the problems yes
yeah you and Dr drink can drive have the
same idea which is the correct move King
H7 and it turns out that white doesn't
have any defense to the double threats
of Queen takes B2 and queen H4
simultaneously both of which would
create devastating threats and um yeah
so Queen G5 is a threat Queen B2 is the
threat Queen H4 is a threat and at the
end of the day white is not able to save
it
um
so for example uh if white wants to
again reinstate this sort of Queen F5
Checkmate uh sorry Queen F5 threat with
a Perpetual check now after Queen G6
Queen d8 is no longer check so the
double attack on the rook and pawn is
decisive and so yeah King H7 is the
winning move here uh hopefully I can be
excused for not seeing that from this
position rookie five is the best because
uh black wins with a king H7 here
um so so yeah that's uh
so yeah hopefully that uh that that
that's that's an excusable mess
um yeah so good session today I think
that the examples today were were of
pretty high quality and high difficulty
which is good
um
So yeah thank you so much for tuning in
um and yeah I'll see you guys next time
bye